[Musique]
ah perruque c'est quelque chose qui me
rend un petit peu agressif c'est une
notion qu'on aime pas trop
pire de l'être ce weekend plusieurs
dizaines de personnes à la chevelure
rare se sont retrouvées à Fontainebleau
en Seine-et-Marne pas question de se
lamenter ou de penser aux implants
capillaires ces choses affichent leur
calvitie sans complexe Xavier
des choses je vous déclare membres
d'honneur je vous prête serment sur une
boule de billard et porte leur paille en
sautoir quand les chauves ne se cachent
plus ils s'associent en confrérie le
cheveu rare mais les idées larges pour
boule à zéro et crâne d’œuf ne sont pas
les seuls critères de la calvitie
ici notre confrère est chauve naissant
il va pencher son crâne il ne peut pas
encore accéder au gras de chauffe
couronnées parce qu'il a encore trop de
cheveux ici donc il doit être patient et
moyennant la patience et les années ben
peut-être qu'il arrivera à monter de
grade puis vous avez un chauffe couronné
ici sans tricher les cheveux sont partis
sur le sommet et reste sur le côté et
puis alors notre idéal à tous c'est de
venir chauffe intégrale comme notre cher
ami Ernst si je vous dis le perruque
vous me dites quoi ah perruque c'est
quelque chose qui me rend un petit peu
agressif c'est une notion qu'on aime pas
trop même pas du tout
intolérant en matière d'implant et
autres artifices capillaires s'échauffe
sont beaucoup plus ouverts en ce qui
concerne les frontières belges allemands
ou français le club est prêt à
accueillir toutes les nationalités
évidemment pas de risque de cheveux sur
la langue actuellement un groupe qui va
se constituer au Canaries
un autre en Hollande et j'espère
en Grèce puisque on a déjà une bonne
touche
de ce côté là crân nuisant et firent ton
sur ces choses ont connu leur jour de
gloire à Fontainebleau des garni et fier
de l'être au point d'Antony Laurine
international
encore
[Musique]